some could have gotten mad and said well
then I'm out of here because you don't
appreciate me and you thought that I was
somebody else and I'm insulted
but you obviously probably didn't do
that right and as they were following
you around again some people could have
gotten mad said these people were
breathing down my neck and they won't
leave me alone but you you kept going
with it I was one of the first black
directors in TV and Hollywood before me
it was Michael Schultz I think Stan
Lathan and where he kept in the what jr.
what to have that opportunity I went
through a lot I give an example of
things and I this is my book I was the
first black to return doubt was ever and
I was so happy because it was a top hit
show on TV and then a good job with nice
landing and other shows that Falcon
Crest and other shows they said ok give
you a shot come up to the gate runner
brother Studios roll down the window
look at the security guard before I
could say a word that security guard
says up who are you delivering for
I said no no no I'm not delivering for
anybody
I'm that's first like the rector on that
was I'm here early because I want to be
it's like this one clove to the side I'm
always early so I pull over to the side
and it's like I feel be at nine o'clock
it's 8:30 that was eight 4850 compliment
when I say kiss on the phone he calls
update office and let the Remi back in
the phone looked over at me back on the
phone that's the phone and say I'm here
egg is like this yes no it's my first
day what year was this late seventies
early eighties in Los Angeles
oh yeah I buy the team says one day and
I was doing I thought wouldn't crest
going to my motorhome I much of my hand
what by train back treat now listen okay
guys man up you got something to say to
me say it to my face what are you
talking about sir I heard what somebody
sex money call me tell me stand up god
you're the director of the phone would
never say that we talking about you some
mistake I think that you misheard us get
my tray
turn around start walking time at home
I'm gonna set a falcon crest' one day
we're up in Napa Valley and I'm filming
and first ad we're filming in a
restaurant it's a practical location so
we're there you know just to shoot and
it's supposed to be quiet in the kitchen
but they're gonna be totally shooting
him so the first ad very arrogant guy we
start shooting had to cut us third time
because there's noise in the kitchen I
say cut say hey man there's noise and
the kids will to calm down he said he
says to me and I'm quoting in front of
the cast in the crew if you want him to
be quiet go back there and tell him your
own damn self but that time I really had
it aside threw down my head sitting I
was pushing toward a guy Jane Wyman
grabbed me by my arm she looked me in my
face she said took a deep breath my
director's chair pop my headset back on
time for lunch came back she had fired
him she apologized for
see what I'm saying so knowing that
people wanted you to fail but still
holding that confidence I mean we've all
had times when we've been tested and we
can tell someone's egging us on how have
you learned to keep your cool and now
you say you meditate there are people
who want you to fail but there are great
people like Jane Wyman I want you to
succeed and David Jacobs gave me several
more chances at Knot's landing and Larry
Hagman at Dallas my first did that show
first back-to-back trying Dallas who
said to me nice to meet you young man
we're gonna get along real fine as long
as you help me out every day by 3:30 man
I guarantee you every day you'll be up
to 3:30
can we come back and do more and more
shows I could think of stories of people
who there's some great people in this
industry I mean when I say great I mean
they don't have to give you a shot
because they're good human beings and
they see beyond your color to your
humanity and your ability that they do
something then that they don't do it
loud they do it because they're good
people and if you deserve it they give
it to you they give it a shot because
they gave you that chance you do more
than you better than you could ever do
because yo that to them and yourself
there's some damn good people in this
industry when I came along I met a few
of them that changed my life I mean with
that that's been a you know to be very
honest with you and a place in my
biography
I grew up as a racist I hate it all with
people because of slavery and
segregation so my father and mother go
through I just hated wait wait just and
I'd go for the angry young black man and
that was tall and awkward I didn't talk
much and I wrote journals and stuff and
he's two billing people I never forget
who changed my life mrs. Jean Walker
English teacher very stoic and I
disliked him in the class she told me
nine times that's write in my journal
when she was teaching I just ignored her
this vase it's white woman
one day she says do stay here after
class just give me that book I said what
the John will give it to me
someone give me anything she said if you
don't give me the journal I'll fail in
the class and you can't pass through the
generator pissed off I hated her come
back to class at next several weeks
before a spring break and looked at her
like if I could punch in your damn face
man
Spring Break hints come back to class in
the first day I'm going into class she's
a Duke come here she gives me back my
journal in this book I said what is this
she says the national poetry contest
book so why do you like we give this to
me for she says look on page 49
she put to my poetry poems in there
anyone
I looked at her this somebody I hated
she had taken she read my book my
journal took the best poems out and
submitted them to a national poetry
contest I won I was speechless and she
knew I was speechless she says there's
nothing to say you're good at what you
do that changed my mind I wasn't quite
sure how to think about race then
because that never happened to me and
then I went to the Community College and
you know James Hall was the Dean he was
in the Navy and stuff and I got a
scholarship to Boston University after
Dutchess and I worked there but you know
it was difficult I got a scholarship for
in classes but I had to work for room
and board and food and everything I was
working seven days a week exhausted and
my grades weren't that great and severus
just going to the arts college I decided
I was gonna come home to the Kip see I
was going to stay there for you you're
quits bu and get a job make money so I
can save it for that at IBM I went doing
a summer of to visit my friends at BU
and I'm leaving dr. hall see hey Duke
come here I gotta go duck says Duke come
here come here
oh this guy's a boring ass white and I
can't stand us I count those office just
to be courteous he says how was he I
said okay how you doing dude okay
he's going to Boston University right
yeah well I'm not I'm I'm going but I'm
quitting I'm staying the kids he for a
year and gonna go back next year racism
no you're not what are you talking about
goes into his vest pocket and he has an
envelope to me I said what is this he
open it in the envelope with a check of
his own money that paid for three years
of my room and board at West University
I looked in this man's white man's face
I'm supposing he doesn't say a word look
at each other
I just thank you he did not say I would
put out his hand and he said don't
disappoint me
something happens to your racism after
that it's supposed to be your evil enemy
that's responsible for that negative in
your life and everything the devil the
system the creature just gave me a check
to cover all of my expenses for three
years how do you hate that life changing
so I evolved you know in my humanity to
understand you cannot put a blanket on
any of everything it's all about human
being the person the individual who they
really are behind what their skin color
is behind what their words are their
possession it makes a little difference
to know the human if they respect you
you respect them simple Arab Chinese
Japanese Jewish white black green
Hispanic those topical services that's a
limited perception you have the courage
to engage people at their level of
humanity you're living it's easier to
dismiss you because I see you and I make
assumptions I learned a long time ago a
s s u m e means it makes it s out of you
and it has out of me to assume and I was
taught by those two incidents it was
incredible
I wasn't for those two people I wouldn't
probably be here today and never asked
for anything all they say is to be your
best
that's a reward it's the truth
you